so if you're a businessman and and
you're thinking about how to incorporate
political risk in your investment
strategies what do you need to do first
diversify emerging markets are much more
unstable than the developed world if you
were investing in the last 40 years and
you want to just be in the United States
or just be in a couple of European
countries that was okay but if you're
investing primarily in emerging markets
the outcomes are can be radically
disparate and very quickly which means
you're going to have to take a lot more
bets to have the same sort of type of
risk profile that's important to know
can be difficult to do another point is
that you need to be a first mover
because in environments where there's a
lot of political risk folks that come in
early actually can help shape the
environment the political environment
the regulatory environment the joint
venture environment to be tailored
towards them second and third movers
won't necessarily benefit from an
environment that's been tailored for a
guy that invested before you did that's
much more important in places where
legal structures and systems are much
more opaque and much more fluid than it
is in a country like the United States
and the other thing I would say is that
if a promo for a broader investor
perspective and not looking at it as a
businessman is that we've talked about
emerging markets as if they are in some
ways a united asset class they're not
the jasmine revolution was never going
to happen in China the average Chinese
after 30 years of ten percent plus state
director growth is happier with their
government than the average American is
today with the American government
there's a lot of stability in China over
the near to medium-term there isn't in
Tunisia there isn't in Libya there isn't
in Thailand there isn't in Sri Lanka
there isn't an Argentine there are other
countries that haven't blown up yet
where there's very strong political
instability and yet people that want to
invest in emerging markets their funds
the growth funds and your retirement
accounts they say put my money in
emerging markets frankly there's going
to be a lot of volatility
around something like that to the extent
that you have the ability to pick and
choose you 12